i can switch side which is great okay um
so sorry for the for the weight um
so this is a new talk you you you may
have seen some of my previous talks that
you know that are available in
various places
but this is actually a
somewhat new talk so there's a bit of
new material here
and i've been asking the question
myself the question for several years
now
is uh you know what would be the
architecture of a autonomous ai system
so kind of uh you know taking things
from first principles
and then um we are to the point where we
have techniques that you know allows us
to you know train systems to represent
data
uh we have uh
you know a good knowledge of
reinforcement running and optimal
control and various things like this is
there a way to assemble all the pieces
into a consistent
architecture that may
have the properties of intelligence that
we observe in animals and humans and so
the first question that we might ask
ourselves is um you know how do
you know what could machines learn learn
like humans and animals and and the
first thing that we uh we observe is
that uh babies learn
uh uh how the world works mostly by
observation in the first few months of
life they can't act very much in the
world they mostly observe
and simply by observing they are
accumulating an enormous amount of
background knowledge about the world
in the form i think of
models of the world predictive models of
the world
um and and so
you know there are concepts like uh very
simple concepts like being able to
distinguish uh
animate objects from inanimate objects
even learning what objects are the fact
that they're objects in front of others
um
the fact that when an object
uh hides another one the the one that's
hidden is you know still exists the
notion of object permanence which baby
is learned very early in the first two
months of life
um the fact that when you
you put certain objects uh on
on the table for example they will they
will stay up and some of them will fall
uh the fact that uh an object that will
not be that is not supported will fall
so things like this where um you know it
takes about nine months for babies to
learn that uh gravity has an effect on
objects and that objects that are not
supported will fall um so if you show um
a nine-month-old baby uh the little
scenario at the bottom left here where
you see a little uh car uh you know
moving off a platform and you know
appearing to float in the air
a nine-month baby will look very
surprised and look at this for a long
time because uh her model of the world
is being violated but a six-month-old
baby will not actually look at it very
surprised because uh six months old baby
has not yet acquired the
notion that objects that are not
supported uh will fall and so what you
know a big mystery is uh you know how is
it that with all the the powerful
techniques that we have we cannot get a
self-driving car to learn to drive
itself whereas you know any teenager can
learn to drive a car in about 20 hours
of practice
and the difference is uh you know the
teenager has a pretty sophisticated
model of the world uh telling him that
or her that uh you know if you drive
next to a cliff and you you turn your
wheel to the right the the car will run
off the cliff and nothing good will will
happen
whereas if you don't have a good model
of the world you you will have to run
off the cliff multiple times to realize
it's a bad idea right so if you are in
kind of a reinforcement learning
scenario without a
model of the world you'll have to run
off the cliff thousands of times before
you figure out that it's not a good idea
and before you figure out how not to do
it okay
so that's the
um you know how do we get machines to do
this and i think it's one of the main
challenges
of
of ai today uh machine learning in
particular but aid more generally
um so one big question is how do we get
machines to learn uh representations of
the world but also predictive models of
the world and this i will answer with uh
something you know with supervision but
also
uh other things i'll talk about the
second question is how do we get
machines to reason uh so i was alluding
to this in the
in the in the questions at first um
uh
what is it really uh what does it mean
to reason uh when you know the system is
supposed to be differentiable and and
everything and um
uh
how to do it in a way that's compatible
with uh
you know backdrop essentially or
gradient-based uh gradient-based
learning
and then the third thing is how to learn
to plan complex action sequences and i i
don't have any complete answer to this
but i'll i'll try to give some idea of
how we might approach that problem okay
so um how do humans and animals learn so
quickly i learned you know i i told you
about the you know what uh how baby you
can learn models of the world really
quickly it's not just babies it's also
animals um and everything and you know
there were work you know classic work in
um in in psychology this is a slightest
i stole from my friend gentilematic uh
uh craig in particular kind of craic in
the 1940s who who basically you know
said that uh
common sense in the in humans is not is
not
knowledge but it's just it's a
collection of models essentially
um okay so i'm going to jump right in
and make a proposal for an architecture
for autonomous ai system
um this is the kind of stuff that you
can allow yourself to do when you uh
when you're uh
you know a turning award winner um
and and people you know there's there's
a chance that people will not laugh at
you okay um but you are welcome to laugh
at me all right i i welcome uh
harsh criticism okay so here is a
possible architecture a possible
architecture is composed of
uh i'll start with the world model so
the war model allows uh the
intelligent agent to predict what's
going to happen before it happens okay
so the role model gets an idea what the
state of the world is and that estimate
of the state of the world is provided by
a perception module okay that estimates
the state of the world which of course
is incomplete
and then the word model allows the
system to predict what's going to happen
in the world either because the world is
evolving or because
there's a sequence of actions that the
agent wants to take which will drive the
the world to a particular direction okay
then
then there is a cost module so that cost
basically measures the degree of
discomfort
that uh the agent
feels if you want or or is in so
essentially the cost function takes the
predicted or actual state of the world
and then compute a cost um
that indicates to what extent the agent
is unhappy right you can think of it
this way that cost is composed of two
sub modules uh one called an intrinsic
cost which is sort of a hardwired
immutable module
that essentially
implements the the basic drives of the
system right so if you want to hardwire
some behavior in the system you don't
program the behavior you just design an
objective function in such a way that
when the system optimizes this objective
function it will actually
have the behavior that you expect okay
so
the fact that this is hardwired
basically controls the what the what the
agent can do and then there is a critic
and the world of the critic is is
basically a trainable cost function
whose function is to predict the future
values of the intrinsic cost
if you want so basically it gives the
agent an idea of what's going to happen
uh of the potential
positive or negative outcome of a
particular situation
uh where the critic looks at the
predicted state of the world and can
tell the agent this is going to turn
good or this is going to turn bad
essentially
um
now
there are a couple other modules in
there one is the actor so the role of
the actor is to figure out what sequence
of actions
uh can i take
so that according to my prediction given
by the word model and and given the cost
i can take a sequence of actions that
minimizes the cost
okay so if you know anything about
optimal control think of this as model
predictive control you can predict what
uh what the system you want to control
is going to do using your model you have
a cost function that you want to
minimize and what you can do is figure
out a sequence of actions that will
minimize your cost according to your
prediction
so that's the actor the short-term
memory i'm not going to talk about it
right now and then there is this
mysterious module on top of it called on
top of everything called a configurator
which apparently has no input but it
takes input from every other module
essentially and what it does is that it
configures all of the other modules for
a particular task at hand
so think of the world model as not being
a completely generic quad model but what
model you can configure
to be appropriate for a particular
situation that you're encountering or
problem you're trying to solve
and
and that configurator basically uh
primes the perception system to kind of
detect the right things extract the
right information from the environment
primes the world model to do the right
predictions that are relevant for the
task and then configures the cost
function uh to kind of achieve a set
goal that he thinks is uh is appropriate
so it's kind of a bit of a
director like a you know a music
director kind of thing
um
and i must tell you right now that yeah
i don't know how to build a configurator
but the rest uh i have some idea
okay so there's several ways in which an
agent like this can decide to act or not
um so one is uh
something i call mode one this is by
analogy to daniel kahneman's uh system
one essentially which consists in just
you know getting a percent from the
world running through the perception
system with extracts which extracts a a
representation of the state of the world
called s0 here
and then that goes into
a module you can call it a policy module
and that policy module directly produces
an action that goes into the world okay
so that's kind of reactive policy it's
the kind of things that you know humans
and animals do subconsciously without
thinking about it
now simultaneously with this you can the
system can use it for model tools so
predict what would have happened
uh and what the cost would have been um
uh according to its own water model and
then store the result in the structural
memory for future
reference because it needs that to be
able to train its its critic and to
train its water model as well
so that's relatively simple and now
there is mode two so mode two is akin to
uh what's called a model predictive
control in optimal control
so it's a perception planning action
cycle where
the system kind of makes a you know a
percep um
x that goes into the perceptual module
called the encoder here
that makes an estimate about the state
of the world and then you run your world
model for multiple time steps
um and the actor proposes an initial
sequence of actions to take
the cost function computes the cost and
then by some mechanism possibly gradient
based possibly other
the actor optimizes the
imagined sequence of actions
so as to minimize the cost according to
the prediction made by the by the model
okay so this is classic model predictive
control people in robotics and optimal
control use this all the time
um and then once you've done this uh
this planning you send the first action
of the first few actions to the
effectors uh in the world okay nothing
uh particularly new about this except
the fact that we're going to learn the
world model um
uh let me skip this one out okay so um
as i said there is a
a cost module that's composed of two sub
modules one is the intrinsic cost
intrinsic cost is composed of multiple
sub modules each of which is engineered
to
drive the system towards
achieving particular
tasks or or guaranteeing certain
conditions okay the battery is low the
system has to go
um you know find a
plug to recharge its batteries um
you know things like that right um
and then the the trainable part of it
the the critic
which basically using the short-term
memory can recover traces of
previous states
and future costs and kind of train
itself to predict future costs from uh
from current states
so this is actually done uh this way you
can have uh the short-term memory that
whenever the agent uh acts in the world
it stores triplets of
uh
the the state uh or the representation
of the state together with the intrinsic
cost that was associated with it
together with a timestamp or something
like this
and then what you can do is recover a
past
state together with a
a future
intrinsic cost and then train the critic
to predict to predict the future value
of the intrinsic costs from the past
value
of the state okay so if you have some
sort of buffer uh to remember the
sequence of the states you can you can
train the critic of course you can train
the critic to not just predict one
future intrinsic cost but some
combination of future uh
future costs in reinforcement running
people use exponentially weighted uh
future costs but you don't have to do
that um okay so we come to the crux of
the question is how do we build and
train the world model and this is really
kind of the centerpiece of the talk here
so the main issue there is that the
world is stochastic so if i have let's
say a neural net that i train to make a
prediction for what's going to happen in
the world
um
even if it's a probabilistic prediction
um
you know it's going to have to make one
prediction and
if if i train it with something like lea
squared error
uh
misquote error the system will basically
have to predict the average of all the
possible outcomes that can happen in the
world so if i do this experiment where i
put a pen on the table and i let it go
the pen every time i repeat the
experiment might fall in a different
direction and the prediction that my
system will provide is you know
basically a kind of transparent version
of the pen in all possible orientations
which of course is not a good prediction
right
so i'd like the system to be able to
make
sharp predictions but different
predictions depending on
things you cannot predict
which could be a latent variable one way
to handle this
and so so here is an example for
example if you train a system release
square to make a
to do video prediction uh you get this
this kind of prediction you observe here
at the top of the little girl when she
kind of moves to blow on uh
the candles
the prediction becomes blurry those are
predictions made by a large
convolutional train on video and because
it has to predict the average of all the
possible icons it makes a blurry
prediction
let me actually repeat this video
so there are techniques with legend
variable techniques so uh that is an
example of what you see at the bottom
these are predictions for trajectories
of cars on the highway
and uh you see those blurry in the in
the second column from the left uh very
blurry prediction this is uh
essentially a large convolutional net
that predicts the next uh
the next frame um
if you add latent variables to your
system
um
so basically variables that you sample
um in inside of your system your system
can make multiple predictions but it's
still very difficult to actually make uh
multiple predictions
so um that's the i that's the the the
problem that self-supervised running
faces uh there are multiple
possible prediction you know
continuations of a video uh multiple
things that can happen and how do you
deal with that uh uncertainty and so the
immediate reaction uh you know if you
are brought up in a kind of a normal
university is to say well you know don't
predict a single point predict a
distribution the problem is that we know
how to predict distributions for
discrete things like like words in the
text we don't know how to
represent distributions for
high-dimensional continuous things like
images
and so we
so
i'm ready to abandon the idea that we
need to make probabilistic predictions
okay and i'll i'll i'll try to convince
you of this
um
so this uh
but there is this idea that by training
a system to make uh
to basically capture the dependency
between let's say the past of a video
and the future of it that system might
learn a lot of basic knowledge about the
world uh the fact that you know the
world is three-dimensional that there
are objects that objects you know might
be at different distances that objects
are animate or inanimate that objects
obey gravity and intuitive physics and
and and that you know animate objects uh
behave in certain ways and so you can
you can sort of imagine a system that
would build
concepts like this by sort of training
itself to to make more and more uh
long-term predictions uh in video
but the way to handle this i think is
this idea of energy-based models which
i've been trying to advocate for quite a
long time
it's basically the idea that you do not
parametrize a predictor
to predict a a y from an x okay you
observe an x for example a video clip
and you train it to predict why um
you can only make one prediction so what
i'm gonna use instead is uh one of those
energy based models so basically it's an
energy function it produces a scalar
energy and what it tells you is whether
the x and the y that you propose to it
are compatible is why a good
continuation
for
x x being a video clip
okay and there might of course
be multiple y's that are compatible with
a given x okay so i kind of represented
this symbolically here on the right
where you have a uh two uh scalar
variable x and y
and the the the black dots are data
points okay so obviously there is a
strong dependency between x and y but
it's not like there is a function that
maps x to y it's more like a complicated
dependency for any value of x there
might be multiple values of y perhaps
infinity of values of y's that are
compatible with it
so the way i want to capture the
dependency is through an energy function
which will take low values on the data
points and higher values outside and
that's kind of symbolized by those kind
of uh
you know level curves if you want
in this in this diagram here okay so we
get regions of low energies that
basically are around the
regions of high data density and then
outside of those regions the energy goes
up okay that's an ideal energy-based
model and
a big question is going to be how do we
train a system like this okay how do we
build it and how do we train it what
architecture do we give it
so we can use an energy-based model to
do prediction but not in every case but
the way we do it is basically by finding
a y
of which there might be a multiple that
minimizes the energy function for a
given x okay
um
okay let me skip this you can turn an
energy based model into a probabilistic
model in certain cases where the energy
has the right property
using for example a gibbs boltzmann
distribution but i'm not going to insist
that we do this in fact i'm going to
insist that we don't do this
okay so um there are a particular type
of energy-based models that are
particularly interesting and there are
energy-based models that have latent
variables in them which are called
latent variable ebms
and the latent variable ebm is basically
again an energy function that now
depends on three variables not just the
x and y that you provide to it but also
a z that you do not provide
and what the system will have to do is
basically minimize the energy with
respect to z so find the z that
minimizes the energy for a given pair x
y
and then the energy you get by
minimizing here
with respect to z you call that f of x y
okay now z is eliminated by this
minimization so think of this as
inference and think of z as capturing
the information that is necessary to
predict
uh
the compatibility between x and y that
is
not present in x uh uh might be present
in y but it's basically not present in
uh in any of the two okay so think uh
for example imagine that
x is a view of a scene
and then y is a different view of the
same scene i've moved the camera and now
i have a different view of the same
scene
how can i be sure that there are
different views of the same scene and
they are not views of different scenes
if i knew
what the transformation parameters were
from the first view to the second view
um i would be able to establish that
those are probably two views of the same
scene right
so it would be useful to to know that
transformation and i can view this as
basically a set of latent variables
okay
let's say x is a short video of
a car i'm following okay on the on the
road and then the video stops and and
why is uh
a follow up of that video when the the
car was coming on the fork in the road
that was the kind of two vertical it
could take so the car could go left or
go right
um
uh if y happens to be the situation
where the the car in front of me goes
goes right
uh uh then the z variable would take you
know one particular value and if it goes
to the left you would take another value
and i cannot predict in advance uh
whether the car is going to go to the
left or to the right but
if it has decided you know i can um i
can assign a value to the latent
variable to figure out what is the best
explanation for this y given this x
okay
now how do we train an energy-based
model
uh and that's that's really where things
start to become interesting
there's basically two classes of methods
and anything you've
you've um
if you have a question i'm not sure this
is a question or not
[Music]
yes
yeah please so i have this um
growing feeling that model parameters
are seen as a constraint in deep
learning to
make a model fit the data
and i would like to have your thoughts
on
this idea of making
model parameters irrelevant
so an example of this is basically the
ebm you're showing
where
none of the slides you showed showed a
model parameter it's only about fixing
the data using
some potential distribution or another
example is a is the bayesian view where
you don't assign a scalar to the weights
but you assign a random distribution so
yeah i would like to have your thoughts
on making uh model parameters irrelevant
in the future or not um yeah
i don't think we can make that
irrelevant frankly because um
uh because of you know intractabilities
that come with sort of full major
approaches where you you have
distribution over parameters instead of
actual parameters
and so
you know i
i like the idea in principle but you
know in practice
[Music]
you can only use it in kind of you know
certain cases but i haven't really
talked about training yet i mean that's
just what i'm i'm coming to and uh
basically all the methods that you've
you've ever heard
fall into one of those two categories
i'm going to talk about okay
thank you
um so
uh
so there are two ways to train an
energy-based model and this also applies
to probabilistic models by the way uh
the first way is contrasting methods and
the second way is regularized methods so
contrasting methods consist in
uh let's imagine uh here in this little
diagram you have a low energy region
symbolized by this sort of pinkish
region here and you have a bunch of data
points which are those those kind of
blue dots
so right now the
region of low energy think of it as kind
of a level set of the energy function
is not very good because
it's got regions of low energy that
don't have any data points in them and
it's got a bunch of data points that
don't are not given low energy so it's
not a very good model so we're going to
apply some learning procedure to it and
what we want in the end is that you know
we want to push down the energy in
regions where we have points and we want
to make sure that the energy energy is
higher in regions where we don't have
points and so contrasting methods do
this by basically hallucinating a bunch
of those green points
and those green points are contrasting
samples whose energy we're going to push
up okay so we're going to take a blue
point push down its energy by changing
the parameters of our energy function
and then take a green point and push
this energy up
okay
and this is a perfectly good method and
you know basically uh every powerful
probabilistic method you ever heard of
does that okay it pushes down the energy
of stuff you want pushes out the energy
of stuff you don't want um and it has to
do this because you know distributions
are normalized so if you give high
probability to something you have to
give low probabilities to something else
and
the problem with this approach is that
in a high dimensional space if your
energy function is very flexible the
number of points that you're going to
have to whose energy you're going to
have to pull up
will grow exponentially with the
dimension of the space
and so if you have a generative model or
if even if you don't have a generative
model but you have an energy model
that uh
you know as a high dimension in its uh
sort of internal representation if you
want
you know you might need a very very
large number of contrasting samples to
make sure that
the energy function takes the right
shape
and i think those methods are doomed
because of that okay
it's very sad because most of the method
that we know about today in machine
learning are contrastive
but i think ultimately for
self-supervised or unsupervised learning
those methods are doomed
um
they're not gonna they're not gonna
scale up essentially so consider the
alternative the alternative is
can you come up with a regularizer
that will cause the energy function to
only want to give low energy to a small
part of the space the space of wise in
particular
okay so you come up with some way
some term in a cost function somewhere
energy or something like that
uh
that will cause your energy function
to uh
basically shrink wrap the data the
regional high data density by
applying a force that kind of brings the
boundary of the low energy region
closer to the data point if you want
okay
and i'm going to be advocating for this
okay so contrastive methods uh uh you
know basically the the only thing you
need to do there is come up with some
loss function that you know is a good a
uh
increasing function of the energy of
data points and a decreasing function
of the energy of contrasting points and
then you need a way of generating
contrasting points and basically all the
methods that
in machine learning that people have
come up with you know most of them a
very large majority of them uh
differ by the last one the precise form
of the loss function they use and how
they pick the contrasting samples
okay
now there are methods that are
regularized and in fact uh i have a big
chart here that indicates to what extent
uh methods that you've heard about are
contrastive or non-contrasting every
maximum likelihood method that uses
multicolor or markov chain multicolored
sampling is a contrasting method
contraction divergence is a contrastive
method it even has that in the name uh
classical metric learning or siamese
networks are contrasting methods um
uh you know noise contractive estimation
minimum priority flow probability flow
maybe not um
gans or contrasting methods um strange
types masked autoencoders and denoising
autoencoders also contrasting methods so
basically a lot of the models that
people use today in machine learning and
ai obviously are contracting methods and
i tell you they're doomed okay that
sounds uh weird because they all work we
know
but uh for the type of problems i'm
interested in which is uh capturing
dependencies in high-dimensional
continuous spaces um i don't think
they're valuable
um so regularized method we already have
a bunch of them
perhaps the
easiest one to to think about is things
like uh like vie okay vae is
essentially a regularized method
for
energy-based models there's other
methods like contracting auto encoders
and and you know
and and things like uh battle twins and
vic craig which i which i'll talk about
in a minute
um there's a whole bunch of different
loss functions you can use for
contrasting methods but i'm not going to
go through them because as i told you i
don't believe in contrasting methods
anymore even though i was kind of uh
co-author of some of the early papers on
this um and you know you probably heard
of this thing called info nce which is
very popular at the moment for training
joint embedding architectures for image
recognition and
i think five years from now nobody will
talk about this anymore
um
this is
to say that gans and probabilistic
methods are contrastive but i'm going to
i'm going to skip this and i also
mentioned that dinosaur encoders and uh
you know bird style masked auto encoders
are also
contrasting methods
um but okay let's uh let's jump into
what i think are the most promising
architectures and the most promising
ways to train them
and so the most promising architecture i
believe
is uh
joint embedding uh predictive
architecture
so basically it works like this the
joint joint everything predictive
architecture of japa
has it takes those two inputs x and y
that you're trying to capture the
dependencies uh
of
it runs both of them through encoders
they don't they don't have to be the
same they could be different encoders in
fact s x and y don't even have to be
like the same modality you know one can
be
video the other one audio if you want
um
and then what you're going to try to do
is uh train the system in such a way
that they put the
representation for for y called sy
is easily predictable from the
representation
of x called sx
okay
so there's going to be a trainable
predictor which may or may not have a
latent variable
and what the role of this predictor is
to predict essex xy from sx
okay
so the big
characteristic of this architecture is
that it's not a generative architecture
because we don't have a model that
predicts why we have a model that
predicts the representation of y xy
that's very important because it allows
the model to ignore irrelevant details
about why that you don't care about for
your task okay so the encoder for y may
have some invariance properties that
will let it abandon all kinds of
irrelevant information about why that
you don't want to
force your predictor to predict
okay so let's say i'm driving uh on the
street
um on a road okay and there are things i
care about like the position of other
cars you know things like that right and
and pedestrians and everything but i
really don't care about the
the the trees that are bordering the the
road uh which have you know beautiful
leaves that are moving in the wind is an
enormous amount of information in there
you know incredibly detailed and if i
wanted to use a generative model i would
have to predict every single leaf
in every single one of those trees if i
want to minimize my prediction error
with a model like this where i encode y
i can my encoder can choose to just
ignore this completely not even look at
the trees or maybe look at the trunks
because i don't want i don't want to run
into them
uh but not attempt to predict things
that are just too complicated to predict
not attempt to predict things that i
know are useless to predict okay
so that's the architecture i'm going to
try to sell to you all right
and you know as i said during the
mysteriously during the the question uh
the session initially
uh this is not a generative model
because it's not attempting to predict
why as a consequence it does not uh it
cannot be converted into a probabilistic
model
this model cannot be turned into a
probabilistic model on y
simply because the encoder
may have invariances
which makes it so that
um by taking the exponential minus the
energy and normalizing it i cannot
normalize it okay my the the integral
will will diverge essentially or i mean
it will certainly be intractable but it
will also diverge so i abandoned the
idea of being able to predict why
but i preserve the idea of being able to
capture the uh relevant dependencies
between x and y
and abandon the idea of doing
probabilistic modeling okay it's a lot
to swallow okay because the religion in
machine learning is you know you should
learn probability models and generality
models are the best things since sliced
bread and so i'm telling you to drop
both of them and uh i might understand
you might be a little reluctant um but i
have um you know i think convincing
argument that may or may not convince
you
so um
so how we gonna
so we can train those with contrasting
methods but again i'm going to argue
against them so i'm going to flip
through a whole bunch of slides that
talk about contrasting methods for joint
embedding architectures and the reason i
have those slides is because those
things actually work if the
representation of the the things you're
trying to train is not too large so a
good example of this is siamese networks
and uh you know i had some of the
original papers on this going back to
the early 90s where you show two
inputs to a system that you know are
semantically identical perhaps different
views of the same image and you run them
through uh
two copies of the same neural net and
you train the system to produce the same
output okay so here you don't have a
predictor the predictor is basically the
identity function but it's basically a
joint embedding architecture and because
it's contrastive you have to come up
with contrasting samples
which are you know basically pairs of
images that you know are different and
what you're going to have to do is push
away the two representations from each
other so that you make sure that you
know the system does not
collapse essentially does not
basically ignore the input and produces
constant vectors on the output and so
this contrastive phase prevents the
system from collapsing okay prevent the
systems from basically having a flat
energy surface that gives zero energy or
constant energy to every pair of xy you
force it to give low energy to stuff you
know good pairs and high energy to bad
pairs
and a lot of people have you know come
up with lots of really kind of uh
ingenious uh algorithm for doing this
cynthia and team clear suave oboe i mean
there's a whole bunch of them
um
you know and they appear uh every day
uh and then you know you you train the
system to learn a representation then
you chop off the last layer you plug
your classifier on it and you see how
well the classifier performs and that's
the way you test those systems
uh so it's you know it's somewhat uh
successful in fact it's kind of uh
produced a wave of interest in in uh in
in things like that um
uh
in the last two years or so in in
computer vision
um
but uh and it works for all kinds of
stuff it works for speech recognition
really well it works for
you know translation it works for all
kinds of stuff but i i really want to
talk about regularized methods
for joint embedding architectures this
is really the cool stuff in my opinion
um
so here is a basic idea of how you train
one of those japas
using the regularized method so
essentially you have three cost
functions okay
three terms in your cost function
um
the first one says i want to maximize
the information content that sax
has about x
okay and the reason i want this is
because i want to prevent sx from being
constant or uninformative about x so i
want to maximize the information that sx
provides about x okay in some way now i
need to define exactly how i'm going to
do this okay but i'll come to this in a
minute and it will have to be some
approximation
but the principle is that you want to
maximize the information content that
sx
has about x similarly you want to
maximize the information content that sy
has about y
okay
now if that were the only criterion it
would be trivial you could just set s x
to x and s y to y and that would be the
end of it but there is another criterion
and the other criterion is the
prediction error so you want to be able
to have a predictor here that you're
going to train
in such a way that the prediction that
the
representation for y is easily
predictable
from the representation from x
and this is where the system may choose
to abandon
unpredictable details like the moving
leaves of the trees
okay
it will say okay i could keep all this
information in sy
but if i do i'm not going to be able to
predict
uh to do a good job at predicting
if that information is present in xy
because it's basically random it's like
you know ripples on the pond or or
things like that you know i will have a
very hard time predicting sort of random
things that can happen so um i'm going
to train my encoder so that
the encoder drops that information from
sy
in such a way that now sy becomes easily
predictable from sx okay so it's gonna
be a trade-off between
keeping as much information in sx and
sys possible but also making sy
predictable from sx all right now
of course you know the world being uh
somewhat unpredictable you may need to
have the help of a latent variable that
basically contains all the stuff you
don't know about the world
um that you may still need to be able to
capture but that you you can't extract
from
from x so the z variable basically says
what amount of information do i need
to complement sx so that i can predict x
y
okay that's what the role of z is
and of course you want to minimize the
information content of z
because if you don't do that then
z might just completely take over z
might contain all the information there
is to
to know about sy and your system will
collapse in another way or would just
not look at sx at all
and then just put all the information
about sy in z so what you have to do is
push down on the information content of
z make it as
little informative as possible okay
through perhaps a regularizer
okay so we have four terms really in our
objective function that we're going to
use for training one maximize the
information content of sx the other one
maximizes the information content of xy
one is minimize the prediction error
another one is minimize the information
content of the latent variable
okay
how are we going to instantiate this to
something that actually works okay so
one algorithm i'm going to
describe in particular is this thing
called vcrag this means variance in
variance covariance regularization
um
but there is a number of uh
algorithms that that do things that are
sort of similar
to uh i mean that can be applied to this
sort of joint embedding architecture
although not necessarily the predictive
version of it so one is called byol
that came out of deepmind
a while back
um and it's not completely obvious that
it actually is an uh an instance of what
i just talked about
but it's kind of
sort of seems to be doing something
similar
another one is
this thing called wmse which i'm not
going to talk about another one that
borrowed twins which came out of my
group at
fair
but i had a few quirks and then v crag
is basically a version of other twins
that uh has those quirks uh fixed
so let me talk about this uh idea about
a twin um this uh has been on archive
for a while but it's going to be a clear
2022 paper
uh and it's you know as i said in
improvement of battle twins so basically
the idea there is how do you measure the
information content of the
representation of x let's say okay so
the first thing you want is is that you
want every variable of sx to not be
constant you want it to
change
for to be different for
a different training sample right
so take every component in the vector sx
and make sure that the variance
of that component over a batch is above
a certain threshold let's say one
okay
when i say variance is actually standard
deviation
for technical reasons
so you do this for every component of sx
and you do this for every component of
sy okay and that will prevent the system
from cheating by just making s x and x y
constant
but the system can still cheat it can uh
make
all the components of sx very highly
correlated with each other or very
dependent on each other
which will reduce the information
content uh containing sx
so what we're going to do here is that
we're going to
um map
the sx vector to a higher dimensional
vector
through a neural net with a couple
layers
okay
and what we're going to do to those
things is that we're going to decorate
the values uh
the output values of that neural net
with many outputs
okay
um so
um let me back up actually let me let me
just not talk about the expander let me
just talk about the
those sx variables
so
one way to prevent all the variables
from doing the same thing
is to decorate them okay so i can
compute the covariance matrix of
of the sx vectors over a batch and then
make sure the off diagonal terms
of that covariance matrix are close to
zero okay i can put this in the cost
function is differentiable
no problem
the problem with this of course is that
those variables may end up being
decorated but not independent i really
want them to be independent
uh or at least
have some level of independence so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to map all
of those variables to
a number of uh initially random
nonlinear functions using a neural net
you say okay so i'm going to use a
neural net with the number of uh random
weights uh that is going to map this sx
vector to a higher dimensional vector
okay and i'm going to decorate those
variables
and because they are non-linear
functions of the original variables it's
going to have the effect of making the
original variables more independent of
each other if you want
in fact i'm going to train this neural
net as well
so that um it extracts you know as much
information as possible from the
from sx so that uh you know the the
components of sx are kind of made as
independent as possible right
okay so that's the first quaternion so
the criterion for maximizing the
information content of sx and sy
is a combination of two things uh take
your sx vector map it to a higher
dimensional vector to a trainable
neural net with a few layers uh maintain
the variance or the standard deviation
of each of the variables above a certain
threshold and then decorate all those
variables this will cause
the components of sx to
basically be informative and
somewhat independent okay so you've kind
of
maintained the information content of
both sx and sy
the second term is going to be simply
you know i have a predictor i want to
minimize the prediction error
now in simple implementations of a
v-crack that i use for image recognition
there is no predictor it's just you're
just trying to make s x and x y equal so
think of it as a predictor that's equal
to the identity function
okay and in fact if you do this uh so if
you you take for example images from
imagenet you augment those images by
distorting them you show two distorted
versions of the same image to the
to the the system and it has two uh
convolutional net basically they share
the weights but they don't have two but
you can make them share the weights um
you you run those two images to the the
two convolutional nets and you apply the
v crag criterion on the output maintain
the information content of
sx and xy but at the same time may make
sx and xy as equal to each other as
possible as close to each other as
possible so you do that for pre-training
then you take
sx let's say
and you freeze the network and you train
a classifier and see how uh training
supervised on imagenet and see how well
it performs
and uh vcrack performs as well as all
the other supervised running techniques
that people have tried in the same
conditions okay so it works the same as
everything else but the big advantage
is
it's non-contrastive it's not limited to
a low dimensional representation you can
use very large dimensional
representation
uh you don't need to
scrap for contracted samples and have
smart ways of doing negative mining
you don't need to share the weights
between the two the two paths
at all
you don't even need the two paths to
have the same architecture they can be
completely different the two inputs
might might take different
modalities of inputs
so
you know very
general and powerful and it works just
as well as
other methods um i mean there's kind of
various results that i'm not going to
bore you with
um it kind of works but um but it has
this big advantage that you know it
doesn't need uh
things like batch norm to work it
doesn't need um
you know things like uh
uh
an extra
like a stop gradient or or exponential
moving average or all the tricks that
people use to get those things to work
it doesn't need any of that
um and in fact it helps the other
techniques if you if you use it as well
okay um
so
the next thing is um
you know i
i told you about an architecture for an
intelligent agent which i have not built
okay i must tell you
uh but uh i think the
this idea of sort of uh
the jp architecture
is going to be a good one for
learning world models
um and i think
the reason is going to be a good one is
is the following um
so
there's been some work uh some of which
some of which is mine but there's a lot
of work in in robotics and machine
learning
in uh
predictive models that try to predict
what's going to happen in the world
but basically predicting in pixel space
okay so basically doing video prediction
and um i've argued here i changed my
mind about this you know over the last
two two years
um
the argument i just gave is that we
should not try to predict pixels
i used to be adamant but the fact that
we should and i completely changed my
mind about this
so things like variational auto encoders
predict pixels right any kind of
generality model predicts pixel games
pretty pretty pixels
vcov predict pixels i mean they predict
the stuff that you want to predict what
i'm arguing for is do a joint embedding
so don't try to predict everything
but you know there are simple situations
where you know if you have something
like you know equivalent to a va or
something like this and you're trying to
do multiple predictions by sampling a
latent variable in different ways it
actually works this is an example for
uh you know a self-driving car kind of
application where the the four columns
you see on the under on the right
are predictions produced by something
that is basically akin to a
variation of autoencoders for which you
sample the latent variable in different
ways and you get different outcomes from
those different sampling
whereas if you don't have a latent
variable
you get those blurry predictions okay so
you can do something regenerative models
as long as what you're predicting is not
too complicated
and uh
okay and this you know this sort of
works more or less uh
more or less reliably if if you use
uh this way of kind of you know
inferring actions uh um as a way to
train your policy essentially but uh but
really what i want to talk about now is
um how you're going to use those japas
to build rod models
that can be used for prediction and
planning
uh and again this is not something i've
implemented this is more like a research
plan if you want so i'm telling you
about my secret to what i'm going to
work on for the next few years all right
um and the one idea is hierarchy called
japa so hierarchical japan goes goes
like this because japa learns abstract
representations
within which you can do prediction
we have the option of stacking multiple
layers of a japan so basically take the
representation learn by
uh
you know we sing a simple japan
that does let's say short-term
predictions okay so it predicts x1 from
x0 but let's say we want to do long-term
prediction if we want to be able to do
long-term prediction we probably have to
do this prediction in a more abstract
space where even less uh details are are
being encoded by the representations and
i can do this by basically stacking
another layer of japan on top of the
first layer
so that i have a second encoder that's
going to you know further encode the
representation
of x into a more abstract one
in which there is less information about
x
uh
but with that more abstract
representation i might be able to make a
longer term prediction
okay
so you know if i want to predict um
you know i'm i wanna
i'm in new york city so i won't take the
car but if i wanted to take my car
and drive to
uh i don't know princeton to visit
sanjeev
you know i can predict more or less at a
high level what route i have to follow
approximately how long it's going to
take but i can't know all the details of
which
you know which traffic lights are going
to be happening to be read what track am
i going to be stuck when behind on route
1 or whatever right i cannot predict
details but there is some level of
extraction in which i can make a
reasonably good prediction in the long
in the long run
okay some sort of qualitative prediction
because i have this abstract
representation
of the
you know of the state of the of the
world and the
the
the chain of events that might might
occur all right and so
japa has this property that you know you
might be able to have higher and higher
level of abstractions in your
representations which would allow you to
make longer and longer term predictions
and that's really important if you want
to be able to do hierarchical planning
if you want to plan if i want to plan to
go to uh princeton from uh
from new york um you know i have to uh
go to the parking garage and pick up my
car and then you know drive the car
through holland tunnel and then you know
take the
uh
you know new jersey turnpike or whatever
blah blah blah right so i can describe
to you what sequence of uh
actions i have to take they're not
really actions they're more like
descriptions of a particular conditions
of the state of the world at various
times okay and now i can decompose the
first task into a smaller number of
tasks right so to get to the parking
garage i have to get out of my
apartment and you know walk to the
parking garage to get out of my
apartment i have to
stand up run go to the door open the
door
uh you know run down the stairs you know
things like that right and then all the
way down to millisecond by millisecond
muscle control which of course
i don't need to instantiate from the
start you know they will be instantiated
as i go when i encounter obstacles i
need to avoid and things like that
so you know how are we going to do this
hierarchical planning i tell you there
is no
existing system that can do hierarchical
planning particularly well today
or at least not
unless the intermediate concepts in this
planning have been uh hardwired
handcrafted
but that's the that's the idea that's
the long-term plan for how a system like
this would would run so it would have
one of those hierarchical japans you
know two encoders that you know take x
and uh extract a low-level
representation as zero and then a
high-level representation is two of zero
okay
by stacking the two encoders and then
you start making your prediction at a
high level
so you have a high-level world model
that does long-term prediction uh very
cross-grained
um you know kind of like you know i'm
gonna take my car drive to through
holland tunnel and then you know take
the
uh new jersey turnpike or whatever
um that's kind of a high level
description
uh the goal ultimately being you know am
i near princeton
and
the planning at that level is going to
find a sequence of high-level actions
which are not really actions they're
more like conditions
that uh think of them as sub-goals
conditions that
the the state of the world has to
satisfy for
you know for for for me to go to the
next step okay so you know am i in
holland tunnel right so going to holland
tunnel is
uh you know being in holland tunnel is
basically this uh a2 of two okay would
be kind of the first action it'd be more
like a condition uh on the world
um
and then you know a24 would be you know
exit the
uh new jersey turnpike at the right exit
you know to get to princeton or
something
um so okay so my high level task has
been decomposed into
uh sub goals essentially you can think
of them as sub goals and now i have the
level below which now is going to use a
finer grain prediction
to figure out like what sequence of
actions do i have to take now to satisfy
this first this first condition
i don't have to run it for the entire
segment i just have to run it to the
first condition
and uh
and that you know i can kind of keep
doing this all the way down to
as i said millisecond by millisecond
muscle controls
so that's a sort of a conceptual idea of
how to do hierarchical planning
uh
with trainable world models whose
architecture is one of those
hierarchical japas okay this all kind of
fits if you want but again i have to
tell you i have not implemented this and
so there's a lot of problems to solve to
actually make this work and it might
actually not work
okay but um but that's kind of the idea
now of course we we have to be able to
handle uncertainty in those predictions
you know am i going to take the
the the new jersey turnpike or am i am i
going to take route 1 or you know
whatever other alternative route i can
take to go to uh to princeton um
uh for that
i need to have latent variables that uh
you know which are part of the japan
architecture that will allow me to
basically explore multiple outcomes
depending on the value of those latent
variables multiple outcomes might be
predicted
and uh
and i might be able to do sort of better
planning that takes into account sort of
multiplicity of
plausible futures
given the multiple values of the latent
variable right
you know again precisely how to do this
may be expensive and not quickly obvious
but at least there is sort of a path to
uh towards that
now you know if you imagine a situation
like this when you're playing a game
like you know what ken was talking about
where
you know the
uh
the opponent is uh uh trying to get you
then the
you have to assume that the latent
variable is going to be maximally
annoying to you is going you know you're
going to pick the latent variable that
maximizes your cost essentially
uh if the latent variable is
a move that someone can make on on a
chessboard or a go board
uh you know you can figure out what uh
what move the opponent can take that
will kind of maximize my cost and then
you can do the opposite for your for
your game so you know things that people
do in the context of games is
sort of
integrated in this
except that in this model
i'm sort of
counting on the fact that the cost the
predictor
uh and everything else is differentiable
and uh
you know it's not the case when you have
a go board that all the moves are
differentiable maybe there's some
abstract representation of it that is
differentiable
but the world itself is not
differentiable okay so basically you
think of the world model
and the cost
as a way of making the world
differentiable
okay now notice that i haven't said a
single word about reinforcement running
here
because everything i mentioned
essentially
has nothing to do with reinforcement
learning it has to do with optimal
control
because my costs are differentiable and
there are intrinsic costs
i can back properly get gradient to them
and so i can minimize them with respect
to actions or with respect to policies
or parameters of some neural nets and
computer policy
without resorting to
external rewards in fact
you can think of the rewards here as
being computed directly by the machine
itself
the
the
intrinsic cost function basically
computes an intrinsic reward okay but
it's differentiable
so whenever you take an action
and the cost
that you incur
is
uh immediate it is because you know you
you you do a percep perception and
someone just pinched you and so it hurts
right so your cost your intrinsic cost
now it's going to light up uh because
someone just pinched you that you didn't
predict
you don't have a way to back propagate
to your actions and change because you
would have to back properly through the
world right
but what you can do is store that state
and store the
the uh resulting intrinsic cost in your
associative memory
and then
later train your critic
to predict that intrinsic cost
given the state and the actions that you
took before that happened
okay
and of course you know people do this in
reinforcement running as well so uh i'm
not saying there's you know anything
wrong with this but
um but this is much more connected with
optimal control than reinforcement
running really
okay so i'm coming to the uh to the end
here uh
you know basically we need to
be able to get self-supervised running
to work so that we can uh
get machines to run models of the world
if those models of the world are
sophisticated enough
the system might be able to acquire some
sort of common sense you know similar to
what animals and humans are doing
possibly okay that's that's a hope
uh
i've argued for the fact that the
architecture should be a joint embedding
predictive architecture that we should
not try to do generative models it's
hopeless
i've argued that we should not use uh
and because they are joint embedding
predictive architectures they're not
probabilistic models so we have to use
the framework of energy based models
um
uh uh because uh
um
you know because those models are not uh
uh predictive i mean i'm not you know
don't predict the variables that they
measure dependencies between
uh you know they they they cannot be uh
they cannot be probabilistic essentially
um
they can be hierarchical because
uh a japan learns
um abstract representations in which the
prediction is performed
um we can stack them and then have more
and more abstract predictions so it's
kind of a you know a kind of a rehash of
the whole idea of deep learning which is
really about learning hierarchical uh
representations of the world but here is
for the purpose of prediction
and then i've argued that we can use
energy minimization essentially with
respect to
actions or something like that as a form
of reasoning so i think
a lot of reasoning that we do
has to do with simulation which is
really what the world model is doing and
has to do with
uh
you know finding latent variables that
can minimize some sort of energy that we
are interested in
so reasoning really in that form is some
some form of
constraint satisfaction really okay
finding the minimum of some energy
function
i think that explains a lot of uh
a lot of reasoning
and the nice thing about this is that it
makes reasoning basically sort of a
differentiable process right
and that's the end of my talk thank you
very much
thank you
thank you